deswegen geht diese ansage draußen
unsympathisch und wie könnte ich diese
ansage besser transportieren als die
wörter die schon gegen mich eingesetzt
wurden gegen dich einzusetzen sascha das
ist für dich werbeschild und herzliche
kommen zu einem neuen video heute ich
war letztens auf der autobahn da magst
du mir gemeint die obersten wartet
wieder rausgekommen
das war ein eher so zu mir jahren ist es
mir egal ist wie ich sollte mal an
nichts was ist denn so ein video er
meistern du bist ein video von
unsympathischen video wieso bin ich ein
video von wieso bin ich in dem video
erleben so ich hatte keinen plan wie das
passieren sollte weil er macht mich
glücklich videos bei youtube und er
meinte mario muss sich auf jeden fall
rein den leute deswegen schauen wir uns
heute zusammenhang mehr guck mal was
gehört ist laut youtube unterwegs und
ich habe mich auch die an die in die
unterste schicht von youtube geben
youtube richtung zwei stangen oder
anleger was die unterste schicht von
youtube ist mein schönberger heraus die
unterschiedlich von youtube dankeschön
dafür aber schauen wir mal fix video
helfen wir für eine starke und lastern
oberkörper so runter abdrücke wieder
hoch runter hoch okay dafür muss man
kurz natürlich lagen den live tag an der
liebe sascha nicht nachvollziehen was
ich da an der stelle gemacht hat ist
eine übung ja also wie gesagt trifft das
ist einfach übungen der letzten sein
oberkörper runter und trainiert hat
bewusst und trieb stars
da wird die habe ich nicht so viel
brustkrebs trainiert deswegen kann ich
schon nachvollziehen dass ein bisschen
verwirrt ist wenn jemand sowas immer
videothek in dem video einfach an diesem
video
okay aber eher unsympathischen schwarzen
unnatürlichen app hat und immer
dankeschön für den zoom auf meinen mund
dieser summe auf die mutter gerade eben
kam der von mir oder kam der von sascha
berge gesehen hatten euch daran erinnert
dass flecken wolf in die kommentare
schreiben weil wenn den zoom von ihm
kommt dann versuchte ich es lustig zu
machen
[Musik]
nicht nur nicht noch mal an dich und
gramm kraft ich war vor allem waren
plötzlich kam
gemessener bisschen näher darauf
eingehen leute entspricht nicht der
wahrheit dass er die drei autofahrer auf
jeden fall eine g klasse ja und dann hat
er seinem vater doch in echtzeit geholt
oder so kulac führen dann auf eine self
habe ich jetzt gelogen mit den drei
autos oder skyworks ab die uns diese
formate
ich meine es ist schon klar dass jetzt
copyrights traktorfahrer nach das ist
selbstverständlich gab es hat nicht
drüber reden
er hat mein gesicht in seinem video
verwendet und viel geld verdient in dem
fall auch analysten von der
amerikanischen investment-bank halt dein
maul gehen davon aus bis zu drei
millionen euro nur durch dieses video
ist nur dass ich das mein gesicht in
diesem video auftaucht das geht nicht
heute man kann nicht einfach das format
ist youtube alter hier weder mega
kreativ kein einziger youtuber hat sich
jemals im format von anderen aus berlin
oder hat irgendwie die gleichen videos
noch mal gemacht oder aber da hat ein
video gemacht was sex oder liebe heißt
liebe es gibt habe ich will heute wieder
eine neue folge diesen youtuber gehört
dieses auto okay kommt auf ihre willigen
israel zu hause ok alles klar okay in
scope 21 gehört dieses auto ja leute wie
gesagt für dem zeitpunkt auf der
autobahn ich noch mehr artikel hat er
mich jetzt wie beleidigt oder so macht
jetzt auf dem kanal zerstörung oder so
habt ihr dann als ich nachts um drei
nach 600 kilometern autobahn fahren
gekommen wir noch angeschaut und zwar
ziemlich scheiße eigentlich zu tat schon
weh leute ich gebe zu ich schaue ab und
zu schon mal videos von sascha sauer und
dann macht er sowas und macht sich
selber ein lustig und
deswegen geht diese ansage draußen
unsympathisch und wie kann ich diese
anlage besser transportieren als die
wörter die schon gegen nicht eingesetzt
wurden gegen dich einzusetzen sagte das
ist für dich
unsympathisch tv
eine frau
[Musik]